us on facebook at c-span history
next on american history tv a panel of
authors discuss the sometimes surprising
fate of nazi and japanese war criminals
in the aftermath of world war ii in a
session titled pursuit of war criminals
to punish or to partner
this 90-minute event is part of a
multi-day conference at the national
world war ii museum in new orleans
titled 1946 year zero triumph and
tragedy
we will now hear about what happened to
those who managed to escape prosecution
yes our panel will begin with pulitzer
nominee annie jacobson
who will talk about the race to capture
nazi scientists and spirit them back to
the united states
to put them to work against the soviets
in the new cold war
then we will hear from dr gerald
steinacker of the university of nebraska
who will talk about the rat lines that
were utilized by nazis to escape europe
and justice
our final speaker will be linda holmes
who will shift the focus to the japanese
who were responsible for horrific
treatment of pows
yet most did not have to suffer the
consequences of their actions
so ladies and gentlemen please join me
in welcoming our first speaker annie
jacobson
[Applause]
thank you so much i'm annie jacobson i'm
a journalist and an author
i write about war weapons
us national security and secrets
i'm very interested in history
i'm particularly interested in how
history gets recorded
and how history gets reported
i
came upon
operation paperclip which was the secret
program to bring nazi scientists to the
united states for our weapons programs
when i was working on another book
called area 51 about the spy uh plane
programs that were going on out in the
nevada desert the u2 and the sr-71 and
the cia's a12 ox-cart and i learned from
the scientists and spies that i was
interviewing about the horton 5 which is
the nazis flying wing
and i learned that the person in charge
of the
horton 5 during the war
was a fellow by the name of sieg
siegfried nehemiah
and he was a pilot and he was a
brilliant engineer he was one of the
reich's top ten pilots
and
after the war he came to the united
states and this is what i found peculiar
nehemiah was so important to goring
that
goring called him my boy
and i found out that when nehemiah came
to the united states under operation
paperclip he became so important to the
u.s department of defense that when he
retired in 1977
he was given the distinguished civilian
service award
and i wondered to myself how do you go
from being that important to the nazis
to being that important to the pentagon
and there began my quest for information
1942 hitler had a dinner party and he
had a small circle of
scientists uh friends there
and there's a famous quote that he said
he said i'm mad about technology
exclamation
and
shortly after the war
1946 year zero
sixteen hundred of hitler's
technologists were on their way to the
united states
under operation paperclip
now many people here or almost everyone
here i'm assuming has heard of von braun
who is part of operation paperclip but
most of you have not heard of the
uh
hundreds and hundreds of others and
that's what interested me these were not
nominal nazis
the myth was that these were the good
germans
um
in the book that i wrote operation paper
clip i highlight
21 of these non-nominal nazis
and just to give you an indication of
their position within the reich
uh
ten of them were members of the ss or
the sa
two of them wore the golden party badge
that little pin
that gave that indicated that you had
favor by the fuhrer
one of them dr otto ambrose
uh
was given a 1 million reichsmarks bonus
for his work during the war
eight of them worked side by side with
either hitler
himmler or goring and they came to the
united states and they built our weapons
programs
and what really intrigued me was the
question
you know how did this happen and what
does it mean
it really is a story about how do you
get ahead
and this was a
conundrum that
american military scientists faced after
the war
and i'll give you a very brief overview
of the program which went of how it how
it came to be which went like this
the um there was an operation called al
sauce and after the you know
as the as the allies advanced the al saw
scientists very quickly learned that
the uh nazis were behind in atomic
energy that was the big fear but they
were ahead in rocketry it's why von
braun was at the top of the blacklist
for capture
but they were also ahead in aviation
uh medicine and this was very important
because the us knew that aircraft would
play a primary role moving forward in
our weaponry and our weapon systems and
the uh the reich had been able to
advance aviation technology
the idea was how do we fly higher
further and faster
and whereas american um you know medical
researchers had to work with rabbits
and guinea pigs
the reich had access to humans in the
concentration camp dachau and auschwitz
and that is where they did a lot of
experimentation putting humans in high
altitude chambers and so forth and these
were the kind of individuals that were
taken to america
but what was really alarming to
the allies to the scientists
in this in the immediate aftermath of
the war was how far advanced
the uh the reich had become in chemical
weapons and biological weapons
and i found this little part of the
story particularly interesting i'm going
to briefly tell you about two characters
the person who led the biological
weapons program and the chemical weapons
program
because
operation paper clip is also a story
about rivalry and so the reason the
impetus for this program
was
the way and the program worked out of
the e-ring at the pentagon the joint
chiefs of staff approved it
and the idea was
that hiring these
nazi scientists hitler's technologists
was the lesser of two evil
evils that if we didn't hire them then
the soviets surely would
and so we took on in addition to the
rocket scientists and the aviation
scientists and the medical doctors
uh the
deputy fur the deputy surgeon general of
the reich dr kurt blum who had been
tried at nuremberg and acquitted and
also major general
walter schreiber who ran the chemical
weapons program
and what was fascinating to me was these
two men fought with one another all
throughout the war um one worked on
offense you know on biological weapons
the other worked on the vaccines to
inoculate um soldiers against the these
kind of weapons they hated one another
during the war and then when they began
working for operation paperclip they
hated one another and it was it's
interesting to me how rivalry
produces supremacy but it can also
produce downfall and i highlight this in
the book and that's exactly sort of the
one moment of expose of this program
because keep in mind this was a secret
program and the government worked very
hard to keep the documents out of the
public eye to keep the backgrounds of
the nazi scientists hidden
and the little crack that happened was
in 1951
when
dr uh major general dr walter schreiber
came to the united states
as part of the secret program and he was
set up in texas and it was kind of a
moment of glory when one of the doctors
at the nuremberg trial who i write about
in in my book operation paper clip his
name was leopold alexander
and he had persecuted many of these or
tried to um
doctors at the doctor's trial
unsuccessfully and and schreiber was one
of the ones who was not present because
he'd been captured by the russians
and he reappeared and was secreted to
the united states and set up in texas at
the aviation medical institute there but
that same month that he was in texas
that he arrived
with the degree of hubris the military
and made a small announcement that he
had come to the united states and they
you know praised him as a good german
but at that same time dr leopold
alexander was doing pro bono work with
some of the very victims
of the medical experiments the few who
had survived at a hospital in boston
and so when dr alexander
learned from a little clipping in a
medical journal that he just so happened
to be reading
that the deputy surgeon general of the
reich was here in america working he
became so incensed that he called up the
military and the military was really
over a barrel and this is the heart and
soul of operation paperclip because the
scientists knew
that the military had a vested interest
in keeping their histories secret
and so there was a big battle that went
on behind the scenes with schreiber
saying you know essentially if you let
them know my past i will let you know
about the sixteen other sixteen hundred
others of us who are here
and dr leopold saying this is an outrage
this man should not be in america
working as a doctor
and the fight
took place behind scenes until leopold
became so upset that he went to truman
himself
um
that's a teeny small victory that i
share with you in the short amount of
time i have to talk about this
fascinating program
when it's
it's darkness is revealed people often
ask me is there does any good come of
this
uh reporting about this story 70 years
after the fact
and to that i say yes because there may
not be a hero
in the story of operation paperclip it
may be peopled with you know darkness
and this idea of nazi science building
up our weapons program
but i always believe as a journalist as
an and as an author that when the facts
get revealed that is its own
personal private and public victory
to report this book i was able to
find new documents through the freedom
of information act that had never been
made public before including long secret
lists
of the actual
crimes that the doctors had committed i
was able to interview
the children of most of the major nazis
that i write about
and learn so much about their
perspective on history
and in f you know
that is that is why i find it so
important to care about history about
how history gets recorded
and how history gets reported i thank
you all so much and i look forward to
any questions you might have
[Music]
oops
so
yeah thank you very much for your
interest in this topic and in my
research i want to thank the organizers
the world war ii museum for the kind
invitation to come to new orleans
and it's always good to be back to new
orleans where i was a graduate student
many moons ago as an exchange student
from the university of innsbruck in
austria
i have 20 minutes
that's not much time so let's get
started
let's start by going back to 1945.
one principle the allied powers could
agree on when he came to germany and
austria was there should be
denatification
but there was little agreement about
what that meant and how it should be
implemented
the us eventually
choose the rule of law through courts of
law a long and complicated process
individual guilt or innocence was to be
established while notions of collective
guilt were briefly discussed but for the
most part rejected
had the western allies not chosen the
rule of law things could have turned out
quite differently as the example of
italy shows
in italy war crime trials and
de-facialization courts the italian term
is esporazione were established but
revenge was widespread
not only was long-time italian dictator
benito mussolini killed in cold blood
without any legal proceedings
but to where an estimated twelve
thousand
twelve thousand italian fascist and
suspected collaborators
went at the killing
in germany things were quite different
as we had heard earlier today
largely thanks to the us the
international military tribunal in
nuremberg against some surviving
prominent members of the certain eye was
created
later it was the united states without
the other allies that held responsible
industry leaders diplomats ss officers
physicians lawyers and generals in 12
subsequent nuremberg trials which went
on as we have heard today until 1949.
these nuremberg trials despite their
many shortcomings set a new standard in
international law which is valid until
today
there were a number of other war crime
trials notability the u.s military court
proceedings in tachao with more than 1
700 war crime suspects
in addition to that the allies set up a
sophisticated system of denuclearization
courts screening for nazi party
membership and office holding during the
ngati regime
in the u.s zone of occupation
13 million germans filed out
questionnaires about their recent past
nazis who had not committed the crime in
the narrow legal sense could still be
convicted in these denotification
proceedings
punishment range from prison sentences
to professional bans or the loss of
voting rights for a certain time
period my research is about the tens of
thousands of nazis ss members
collaborators and fascists from all over
europe
who fled overseas in order to escape
trial and punishment
i wanted to know in my research how
those people got out how they got new
identities travel papers visas money for
overseas travel
how they started new lives and new
careers i also wanted to know which
institutions helped them and what was
their motivation for doing so and the
issue the question for motivation for
these institutions and people helping is
one of the most difficult questions in
my research
the escape of nazis war crimes and
perpetrators of the holocaust after 1945
is among the few major grey areas of the
nazi past
until recently
um
trying to get the image
let's see
nope that's too hard
until recently
our image of nazi escape was more
fiction than facts and often shaped by
conspiracy theories
the odessa organization is a good
example for this odessa stands short for
organization of former s members or in
german
organization
short odessa
it is based on books by the austrian
nazi hunter and holocaust survivor simon
wiesenthal and the novel the odessa file
for british writer frederick forsyth and
here you see a film poster of the 1974
film
the odessa file that fictional idea of
an almost almighty organization of
former ss officers became a reality for
many the escape routes of nazi criminals
and their collaborators were indeed
shrouded in mystery but a single global
secret society by the name of odessa
or any other name for that matter did
not plan them
the reality is much more complicated but
certainly not less interesting
the end of the cold war in 1989 changed
our knowledge on this topic the
afterlife of nazism as i call it after
the end of the so-called surgery
there are two major reasons for the
difference or the changes in research
first a layer of production dropped away
for nazi criminals still alive
investigations and trials started in
many countries in italy the case of
former ss officer eric priepke
gained much attention after he was
apprehended in argentina and extradited
to italy in the 1990s
in the u.s the case of john ivan
damianik an ss guard at soviet
extermination camp who immigrated to the
united states in the early 1950s was all
over the media and i'm sure you remember
the case
in may 2011 he was convicted by a german
court on more than 27 000 counts of
being an accessory to murder
there's a second point why our knowledge
about nazi escape changed since the
1990s archives were opened in east
in the east and in the west for example
cra archives in the united states very
important sources
many archives are now accessible and
offer rich field for future research as
a consequence of new historical findings
more and more structures of this cape
route have come to light
and now let me give you a very short
overview of how war criminals and nazis
fled overseas the routes preferred and
the institutions involved in the early
post-war years
here are some of my findings
the first one
is the importance of italy
italy
played
a central role as a nazi escape hatch
the port of genoa was the closest
overseas port for people stranded in
central europe at this port is where
countless refugees converged looking to
live and start a new life and a better
life away from europe these refugees
were diverse group survivors of the
holocaust
anti-communists late laborers stranded
bmws and so on
and hiding among them hiding in plain
sight were nazis and war criminals in
fact the majority of nazis and warcraft
who fled europe at the end of the war
escaped through italy
it was there that holocaust survivors
and perpetrators cross paths once again
and the quote by simon wiesenthal
captures
this very absurd situation quite well in
my opinion and let's read this quote
together
recently writes i know a small inn near
murano where every now and then illegal
nazi transports and illegal jewish
transports spent the night under the
same roof without knowing about each
other the jews were hidden on the second
floor and instructed not to stare and
the nazis on the ground floor were
urgently warned not to let themselves be
seen outside of the establishment
the italian austrian border region was
quite unique was a quite unique place
after 1945. a kind of
no-man's land
this photo here
of a
gi as you can of course recognize from
the uniform
and a young man actually it's a young ss
man
guarding jointly a red cross building in
may 1945 in northern italy
two weeks after the end of the second
world war illustrates this point very
well this unique situation northern
italy
germany's secret surrender in northern
italy on may 2nd 1945 codenamed
operation sunrise
created a very unusual situation
much freedom was given to the ss and
german army forces there right there i
mean northern italy
u.s news reporters took notice
the headline of the stars and stripes
u.s military magazine read and i quote
did we beat the nazis or not
in northern italy one couldn't tell
after december 1945 there was also no
allied military government in italy
anymore so once in italy nazis on the
run could feel quite safe
but to flee overseas
they still needed travel documents
passports of sorts
this is when a well-known humanitarian
organization stepped in
this is my second finding
travel documents for many nazis and war
criminals were provided by the
international committee of the red cross
the allied refugee organization declared
itself not responsible for germans or
ethnic german refugees
expelled in large numbers from eastern
territories there were about 12 million
so large numbers
given this humanitarian emergency the
international red cross offered to help
out
people refugees with no passport and
unresolved nationality
for example ethnic germans from
czechoslovakia
hungary yugoslavia
poland german east russia
and so on could obtain travel documents
from the red cross
these travel documents were acquired in
italy for the most part from the
delegations of the international red
cross in rome or genoa
based on the principle of neutral
humanitarianism this is very important
neutral humanitarianism these papers
were intended to help all refugees and
war victims
given that there were no background
checks and no real screening of
applicants abuse not surprisingly was
very widespread
not just refugees but also war criminals
and nazis used this simple method to get
away
in some cases with false names
one example is this one here
so this is an application form for
travel document of the international red
cross
and this one is for a certain ricardo
claimant
in his application form
of a travel document of the red cross
clayman claims to be an ethnic german
from northern italy actually from
baltano from stuttgart south tyrol
that's why where i come from and he
wants to travel to argentina
or to immigrate to argentina
the name claimant probably does not mean
much to you except for some experts here
maybe
but you all have seen a photo of this
man before you all have seen a photo of
this man before maybe even
a film a newsreel
his real name was not clayman but adolf
eichmann
one of the organizers of the holocaust
and this is how he fled europe in 1950
with the help of a red cross travel
document
i come to my third finding
in italy there was a close cooperation
between the vatican eight commission for
refugees and the red cross
the vatican commission for refugees
confirmed the identity of refugees in
the letter of recommendation to the red
cross the red cross then without further
inspection issued your travel document
in the words of a red cross official and
i quote
who can question the word of a priest
the vatican commissioner of refugees set
up 20 subcommittees in order to manage
the wave of catholic refugees from
central and eastern europe
this refugee aid was financed largely by
the catholic church of america
let's take a closer look at the leading
figures in these subcommittees
head of the austrian section was bishop
alois fudol
an anti-semite german nationalist and
anti-communist
who had dreams of a christian
national socialism
he considered himself
here you have a photo of bishop udall
he considered himself a bridge builder
between the nazis and the catholic
church especially in the 1930s
in 1937 he published this book here you
see the cover
the title is the grundlar des
nationasitsalismos the basic foundations
of national socialism explaining the
nazi ideology from his point the
catholic point of view
after 1945 he was one of the most
outspoken catholic figures to help nazi
criminals
one of the people he helped was france
dangle
strangle was commander or commandant of
first soviet building
extermination camp
in the death factory of treblinka in
just one year between 1942 and 1943
more than 900 000 people were murdered
and he was in charge of this game
here you see um
a letter of recommendation from the
vatican with the code of heart code of
arms from the vatican
uh commission of refugees for stangle
and here you have his application form
for travel document for the
international red cross
the address that dangle states here
where he lives in rome is the official
residence of bishop alice hudal
the via de la pacia 20 not sure you can
concede here also on this side of
vietnam
i can't point to you maybe you see it
via the apache 20.
and the information here is who does
associate this information this travel
document is confirmed by bishop alice
hudal
most notorious was by no means the only
catholic or christian dignitary helping
nazis
also the catholic leadership was
appalled and shocked by the nazi crimes
they thought nuremberg trials and
denatification is the wrong way to deal
with issues of guilt and responsibility
catholic bishops and cardinals
were outspoken and active in criticizing
the allied war crimes trials and
intervened actively and tirelessly in
favor of the accused
christian notions of mercy and
forgiveness neutral humanitarianism but
also anti-communism played a role in all
of this
catholic leaders worried that for war
crime trials and revenge as they call it
would only weaken the german austrian in
italian societies and facilitate a
communist takeover
i come to my fifth and last finding
because i'm slowly running out of time
fifth
the escape routes were by no were no
secret at the time
they were very well known
various governments were informed the
red cross and the vatican also knew and
several newspapers reported on the
matter in some detail
so when eichmann left europe in 1950 the
structures that facilitated his escape
were no secret one famous example in
this context is the may 1947 la vista
report named after us state department
official in rome
la vista documented in great detail the
escape structures for fugitive nazis and
other war criminals recognizing the
important role played by the vatican
officials and international red cross
documents
la vista's report attracted some
attention in washington and elsewhere
and u.s diplomats approached the
institutions involved for example the
international comedy of the red cross
but the matter was to be handled
discreetly and by the summer of 1947
things changed for good the cold war had
reached italy
priorities shifted
it was decided not to destroy these
underground routes
but instead use them for cold war
purposes
the case of klaus barbie
or klaus barbie
is a good example of this
barbie was the former chief of the
gestapo in lyon in occupied france he
had a reputation reputation as a cruel
torturer killing resistance fighters and
the resting jews after the war barbie
was wanted by french authorities for war
crimes
the us military counter intelligence
however deemed him useful for fighting
communists and after a few years of
service
he was provided with a red cross travel
document under the alias of altman you
see his application form is here klaus
altman
and with the help of catholic officials
in rome he was channeled to south
america
this recycling of nazis for the
intelligence field was quite common as
we have learned in great detail from
research since the late 1990s
some people were deemed more useful as
intelligence assets than on trial in
addition to that allied nations competed
for german minds experts as the case of
wernher from brown prominently
illustrates
they were considered useful and allowed
a new career against the background of
the early cold war
i have one minute left and i conclude
i conclude
it's enough time for conclusion
i have to conclude
i conclude
most nazis and holocaust perpetrators
got out between 1946 and 1950
nobody
nobody fled europe at the war's end in
1945.
let me be clear very clear there was no
uboat submarine waiting for high-ranking
nazis
with the berlin blockade the communists
take over in prague and finally the war
in korea the cold war became hot or very
cold
depending how you want to see it
the new enemy was communism in general
and the soviet union in particular the
persecution of nazi war criminals became
less and less of a priority as a
consequence nazi immigration came to a
halt most nazi perpetrators had little
to fear after 1950 and easily managed to
integrate themselves in post-war
societies
the escape of holocaust perpetrators and
nazis was ultimately only possible
because the interest in punishment
quickly decreased after 1946 1947 the
escape of nazi criminals and their
collaborators should therefore be seen
in the context of denaturation war crime
trials and the early cold war it was not
an anomaly
but an integral part of this history
it also showed both the successes of
western allied attempts of
accountability
new standards in international criminal
law and human rights
but also the limits of postwar justice
thank you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]
very nice
um
aren't you taking questions
no
oh at the end okay
um
uh dr steinocker
uh
talked about
how
hitler's henchmen escaped justice
i'm going to speak about
how the japanese
escaped that same kind of justice
because
the
tokyo war crimes trials
were a little bit odd
because
the
main
focus
was on general douglas macarthur
and his
orders came from washington although he
took
a lot of heat
for what he did which was
commuting the sentences
of
japanese war criminals
although five of them were put to death
he decay
tokyo
tojo
and
general homa
who
supervised
the baton death march and one of my
famous
favorite quotations
of his
is
when he was asked why didn't he give any
food
to the
death marchers for all those days
leaving bataan and and coming
you know to their final
destination he said oh i thought they
had their own food
what a cop-out
but um
the
tokyo war crimes trials
as i said were presided over by general
douglas macarthur
but since
he took his orders from washington
people blamed him
tremendously for
commuting the sentences
of all the rest of these japanese war
criminals
and
you know they didn't people didn't know
that he was acting under orders from
washington because all of a sudden
we had to make nice to the japanese
because
they were our bulwark against russia
and so
these
post-war
tokyo war crimes trials
were really
truncated because
general mcarthur was told to shut them
down as soon as possible
so that we didn't
offend
the russians any more than we needed to
and
the
americans
were
very much involved with
covering up
the
war crimes trials of the
in tokyo
and sugamo prison which was in tokyo
was
empty a few years later and was closed
because it was empty
and
that to me is a tremendous
indication
of what the what the
americans did
in covering up
the
japanese atrocities
you know in the tokyo war crimes trials
because
um
we were
um
under the impression
that uh the russians
were going to
take over japan
and so all of a sudden the japanese were
our bulwark
against the russians
and uh we
all of a sudden were making nice to the
japanese
and uh
this baffled
a lot of the
xpows and i'm sure
les tenny will talk about that
when he speaks
but i just
couldn't get over
when i
did my research
in my second book unjust enrichment
which
for which i borrowed
a legal term
which means
when you enrich yourself
at the expense of someone else you are
unjustly enriching yourself
and so i
felt that was a very good title
for my second book
and
the
uh
the
americans
were so
dazzled
by
the
feeling that the russians
were
going to take over japan
if
the americans didn't make japan a
bulwark
against the soviet union
that
they really bent over backwards
to
exonerate
so many of these other japanese war
criminals
and as i said
sugamo prison was closed
in a few years because it was empty
and
i just found that quite shocking
so i would be happy to take questions
um
you said our q a period was at the end
of
my talk so i would be happy to
participate in any questions you might
have
[Applause]
oh great thank you
oh we can't hear you well i have a loud
voice but this makes it even louder
um
douglas macarthur was taking his orders
from the
federal government the united states
government yes but what do you think his
feelings were about
uh
the attitude towards
the
letting japanese
war crimes go by the board
well
his feeling seemed to be
that
he
was very
very
friendly and forgiving
of the japanese and you know when he was
made
the uh
force the
overseer
of uh japan for several years he was
very
accommodating i thought to the japanese
and
he
you know
i think he himself
uh agreed more with our government than
he might let on
another question in the center
earlier today we heard about
the nuremberg trials and the
exoneration of german
war criminals
ex-nazis joined the government of west
germany to what extent did the japanese
war criminals of those empty dollar
prisons also join into the government of
their country
well
the
major
number of them
took positions in the japanese
government
and
they
they were
accommodated in that way
by general mcarthur because he was
in charge of post-war japan
i hope i've answered your question
we have a question all the way in the
back right here
thank you all three panelists for your
fine talks
and for your written words
uh
the commenter heard earlier
said that
or agreed with you that general
douglas macarthur
took it or followed
his orders from washington
i would add when it pleased him
there i also
with respect to his attitude towards
the defeated japanese
in a book about the great british
general william slim
who achieved victory in burma
when he was told
that
he should allow japanese officers to
keep their swords i think it was
because
general macarthur
did not want japanese soldiers to lose
respect for their officers
general slim
expressed the thought
that
it was exactly what he wanted for those
for japanese troops
to lose respect for their officers thank
you
good old general slim
next question in the center
this question is the director to dr
steineker i rejoin your presentation
very much sir uh you mentioned the role
of the catholic church in getting nazis
on the boat to
argentina and south america did the
catholic church in south america play a
similar role to helping them acclimate
setting up the jobs getting involved in
their communities
um yeah thank you very much for your
question that's a very important
question i just want to point out a few
things maybe if i may
first of all
not all the holocaust perpetrators or
nazis or former fascists went to south
america
near east was very popular destination
as well syria egypt we don't have much
research about that
yet but it's going to change hopefully
in the next few years
and of course north america canada
united states i mean ten thousand former
collaborators many of us as members from
eastern europe from the ukraine and so
on came to canada and the united states
we shouldn't forget that
the role of the catholic church i mean
it's important to
make it clear that in my research i
point out to
the role of individual high-ranking
catholic
officials it is not
it is not yet so well researched what
the top hierarchy including the pope
were thinking about these activities and
how much
um you know what kind of role he had in
this and the the leadership of the
catholic church that's a question
certainly for future research
once the archives are opened uh the
vatican archives i mean the other thing
is
south america yes
the catholic church there was
accommodating and helping these refugees
for a number of reasons because
one obvious reason
uh refugees and
people you know on the run as well
one obvious reason is many of these
people are catholic
one thing that you probably noticed that
these application forms for travel
documents of the international red cross
whenever it asked it asked a question
what religion yeah it's always catholic
we have a question in the back center
this is a question for dr steiner
how did the nazis finance their travels
and was a bribery involved
this is also very good question um and i
have very little time to answer that but
as i said there was no central secret
organization with unlimited money and
gold in swiss bank accounts this is
fiction
it really depends from case to case i
give you a good example two examples one
is the case of joseph mengele dr joseph
mengele
probably well known to everyone here and
his crimes that he committed
experiments on humans when he used this
weight to get out of europe he had
plenty of money because his family was
rich they had a big enterprise in
germany still operating and producing
agricultural machinery so he was staying
in hotels in italy while on the run
aikman had no such sources
he had to rely on
you know
monasteries where he could stay and
people who helped him out and he
certainly didn't have the financial
means to stay in a hotel so it really
depended case by case
a bribery a
primary certainly played always a role
in such uh situations extraordinary
situations you know you had to find
people who would maybe willing to give
or swear that you are actually ricardo
claimant
and then you would uh you know in return
would pay this person
um yes these kind of primaries happened
of course yeah very common in italy yeah
i'd like to address the gentleman who
just finished speaking
uh the the cons what i take away from
this morning's presentations is that
much that was attempted through the
courts
ultimately failed
or
was modified
by
political considerations and it would
seem that in both the case of japan and
but even more so in the case of europe
and germany that it was political
considerations that drove the ultimate
results and my question is um
it rises it raises a question about the
the
the function and the um
the ultimate success
of the
role of justice
and
morality
and seems to
one's conclusion could be that we should
just skip all of that and go directly to
the the political
and let the politicians decide how they
want to resolve this i i would be
interested in hearing your comments on
that
i have an interesting note on that um
and it's a good point
during the nuremberg trials a doctor
named theodore benziger was in jail
facing
you know trial
and he was mysteriously released
to
the u.s army air forces
and he was secreted on a boat and sent
to the united states where he researched
and worked on
defense department programs his whole
life
when he died
in the mid 90s
his new york times obituary lauded his
work and boasted about the fact that he
had invented the ear thermometer
it left out the fact that he was doing
human experiments
um on prisoners having to do with high
altitude studies at dachau and so
the idea
that
supremacy the idea that weapons
development us
you know
excellence in that area
could outweigh
any kind of moral issue was paramount to
the operation paper clip program and
interestingly what you speak about as
well it was the same thing in japan we
were afraid that the russians would take
over and in the united states we needed
to have an offensive program that would
terrify the russians into keeping mutual
assured destruction in balance i mean it
was a precarious time keep in mind this
idea of brinkmanship led
foreign policy and this was the idea of
pushing dangerous policy policy to the
razor's edge which is why we had so many
chemical weapons programs biological
weapons programs all spearheaded by
former nazis and ironically dismantled
by nixon um
and
no longer exist
that's very interesting
good old richard nixon
you can just add my opinion about this i
mentioned the case of italy
and i did so on purpose
um
because in italy the situation was quite
different you know it was also an axis
partner it was 20 years of italian
fascism since 1922.
so the italian case is interesting if
you compare that with austria and
germany of course in particular
and
in italy there was no italian nuremberg
there was no italian nuremberg really
and there was a lot of revenge as i
mentioned in my talk i mean with 12 000
people killed in the immediate post-war
years in co plot
um and i don't
i think it's it's a my opinion it's a
good thing it was a very good thing to
do by the americans and you should give
him credit for that the people who were
in charge of that to implement the
principle of the rule of law
the principle of the rule of law because
that was the right way to start a new
society a better society and make a
clear distinction line draw a line
between the old regime and the new
beginnings of a democracy italy didn't
have that in that way
and in my opinion i think the
shortcomings of italian democracy later
on have also looking back of course
looking back with hindsight have also to
do with that
next question in the center
i'm miss jacobson um
obviously the
world was well aware of the advanced
state of the german rocket program
but it sounds like as we were trying to
prosecute this war and win it it was
toward the end of the war that we became
aware of some of the other advancements
that german scientists had had
so i have two questions for you
one
what would have happened to these uh men
and women had america and the allies
been farther ahead in the research
what would have been their likely
outcome
and and two
i guess if you put yourself in 1945
and you had
i think you'd say this opportunity
um
to take advantage of these resources
what do you believe you would have done
so
it's an in you know it's a fascinating
conundrum and it's really the heart and
soul of the of the dark riddle uh as one
scientist described it that was
operation paperclip
there was no doubt that the us
needed von braun i mean there's a story
i tell in the book about how
the russians would stand there with a
bullhorn you know von braun was in
captivity and they would say like come
to our side you know with a translator
because
they wanted
that battle had begun in the ashes of
world war ii the cold war in essence
what would i do impossible to say it's
to me one of the great joys of being a
journalist because i try to
i try to get in the
the mindset of those who had to ask
those questions in real time and in this
book in particular i was able to do that
by finding the journals
of the man who for example was in charge
of the chemical weapons programs and
this is remarkable i mean you know it
really makes you wonder anyone out there
who keeps a journal if you're writing
sort of your dark secrets and you happen
to be a major general somewhere you
wonder should i really be doing this
because they might wind up at a military
history museum and i might find them or
someone else because
and you know it's interesting when you
when i saw anti-semitism come into play
in that particular case there was a
general named general lukes and he was
he was actually sent to heidelberg
to interview
the the scientists dr ambrose dr
schreiber people who were actually in
landsberg prison at the time and they
would come out on weekends sit around
with dr luke's and discuss how to build
our sarin gas program
and from the journals to answer your
question
you see a real adoration
for these scientists and that really got
into some questionably quasi-moral
terrain when you see in the writings of
the person in charge of this program the
american general saying
well hitler aside you know we won that
war now let's work with these chaps at
making our weapons program the top tier
yeah if i just can add something um you
know the problem the horizon a little
bit here as we
stated earlier it was not just the
united states competing for these german
mines it was really an international
competition the major allies of course
they had direct access and there are
cooperation zones you know german
engineers and so on scientists but also
countries like argentina argentina and
other countries like syria egypt they
sent their missionaries their diplomats
to italy
in order to arrange the transfer of
german
scientists especially military experts
to their countries
and it was german scientists who
developed the first
argentinian fighter jet in the 1950s
because baron was very ambitious of
course and he wanted to be the number
one in south america and his military
and the german engineers helped him in
this endeavor
a question
really for either mrs jacobson or
the doctor
i think the interesting thing to think
about is if you
you're we're focused now on 45 and 46
if you fast forward 30 years
you will come to a time when
the front the focus of journalists
was iceland in a meeting between
president reagan
and the soviet premier gorbachev
they
met in a small house
to negotiate
arms reduction
the meeting concluded rather abruptly at
the end of the afternoon
when
the interpreter for gorbachev
said
you do understand mr president
that all the concessions that i have
offered this afternoon are contingent
upon your abandonment of the strategic
defense initiative
at which point the meeting was over
because reagan slammed his notebook shut
and turned to secretary schultz and said
we're out of here
and the photographs that record
both
reagan and gorbachev
leaving that small house
speak volumes
reagan is visibly angry
and just as visibly agitated was mr
gorbachev
who was buzzing in the president's ear
trying to get him to come back to
negotiation
nine months later
reagan stood at the brandenburg gate
and said mr gorbachev tear down this
wall
the point that i'm making is that there
was
great
concern on the part of the soviets
that they simply did not have either the
technology
the time or the
money
to compete with a strategic defense
initiative they didn't want
the united states to have
both the hammer and the shield
if they didn't have it
if they had only the hammer because
among other things they thought it
threatened
the sudden almost overnight
the making obsolete and 800 billion
ruble investment in offensive weaponry
on the part of the soviets
so i think if you think about that
that competition
for technology was going on and it was
as you've said doctor in international
competition
so i think the stakes were high
and perhaps higher than anyone knew
but it probably explains a great deal
absolutely i mean i think you speak to a
great point which is that
at least with operation paperclip it was
not such a
cut and dry issue as how could we have
how could we have committed this moral
outrage there was real concern at the
pentagon um
i as i report in the book
the intelligence community came to the
joint chiefs of staff with a very
significant document in 1946 and said
you know we must be prepared for total
war with the soviets
and that you know what that presaged
atomic war chemical war and biological
war in concert in a kind of apocalyptic
vision
that then became very real as the as the
cold war progressed through the 50s and
60s and um i love your point about that
final that final showdown over sdi
because i think that really that was the
tip that tipped the the scales um
and it really does make one question
whether or not um
you know
that idea that one must stay ahead one
must be in the poll position in terms of
national security
thank you
next question to your left
uh miss jacobson um i've been out to
alamogordo and visited with some of the
docents and
people that take you around their museum
and talk about
the nazi scientists that came out to
white sands missile base
some of those moved on into huntsville
alabama
tell me about the assimilation of the
nazi scientists
he was somewhat in a guardian in a
situation where the scientists were
living out there but how well they
assimilated the u.s life
and what became of their families very
little is written about that
and
he was of the opinion being able to know
these people a little bit
that they never became u.s citizens in
terms of assimilating into our lifestyle
they had a protection
to stay in the u.s obviously but did
they assimilate to us or did they stay
kind of confirmed nazis as he would say
you know that is a great question and i
find that character um super interesting
and i and i and i i touch upon that in
all of my books because
um
you know the hunt there were 112 nazis
that um that worked there at white sands
with a hundred v2s that were brought
back so we captured the munitions and
the scientists but as far as
assimilation is concerned maybe the best
example i can give is
of some the the person that i referred
to in the very beginning siegfried
nehemiah who didn't work on the rocket
program but rather worked on the
aviation side of things
and i interviewed um
you know i like to track down the living
family members who have that first-hand
experience and i try to access journals
and
i found nehemiah as one of his grandsons
who agreed to let me interview him and
even more interesting to me
agreed to you know he said to me when i
asked him will you talk to me about your
grandfather siegfried nehemiah goring's
right-hand man
later
you know the defense department's
distinguished civilian scientist
and he said yes i will and i will not
only do that i will fedex you my a box
of my grandfather's writings and papers
and journals and awards
and when i went through that box and you
know
side by side with a letter of
recommendation from albert speer
and a letter of recommendation from
albert from harman goring this is during
the war there were letters of
recommendation from defense department
officials but for the assimilation this
note really
you know made me made me think
um
nehemiah asked to be cremated
rather than be buried and he asked for a
simple
paragraph to be read during his funeral
and it said
that he
worked for and respected two nations
germany and america
our next question is to your right
panelists
speak slowly i'm going to repeat your
question thank you
i was impressed with your presentation
about nazi on the run with documentation
but they were not only nazi men in
german they run to argentina into south
america they were also from croatia
you can emphasize also about the act of
odessa but you have to forget it you
have vomited or you should be done also
act of serbia in 1941 i'm now 95 i was
20 years of age
the germany bombarded belgrade and
advertised you can find the library of
congress
you can find on file
they have
for one dead germans if you make any any
against germans will be 100 male selves
killed
50
for wounded
question is
in my city or their city i was a
guerrilla i am now 95
in 20 years of age they have executed
all my class youngsters or 50 years of
of of age
60 60 years of age
they asked teachers get aside the
teacher said no we are lecturing our
children now
second question
we're going to go with the first
question so that they can answer it and
then i'll get you to the second question
uh dr steinocker can you comment on the
uh croatian
war criminals who may have utilized
we've asked you here to talk about the
nazis who act who escaped yeah but do
you have anything on others who were
collaborators or co-belligerents with
the nazis to get out uh yeah i mean the
the role of the so-called ustasha
the fascist
creation
members of the fascist creation regime
they played a huge role in this
there were large numbers of
croatian ustasha fascists escaping
through italy
and in that case actually was a
different
catholic official it was kunus la
traganovic
who was the head of the croatian
catholic
community in rome and he helped many
holocaust perpetrators and croatian
nazis to escape to south america and to
other places
draganovic also worked together with the
csc with the u.s county intelligence
and he was the man who actually
helped to a creation priest poganovic he
helped
um klaus baby to get his travel papers
and so he signed klaus pavise papers and
croatian
monsignor in the home
working for the um vatican commission
for refugees so that's what i meant
earlier was certainly not bishopvalus
alone
it's a little bit more complicated than
that the other thing with reprisal
killings absolutely right horrible
things i mentioned the case of pripke
not in croatia but in italy he was
responsible for reprisal killing of
march 1944 one of the most horrible
reprisal killings or most notorious in
italy when in march 1944 335 italian
civilians were murdered as a reprisal
for the killing of 33
german police soldiers in rome by the
partisans priebke made it to argentina
after the war with red cross documents
and the help of vatican officials he
lived there under his real name
in san carlos de bariloche in the south
of argentina where many others
left lived and had their community
he was even very prominent in the german
school there in a german community there
nobody
i mean it was not a secret that he was
there
but in the 1990s after the end of the
cold war he was discovered
um we're going to go with nathan alex
we'll get your second follow-up after we
make the rounds here
dr steinhacker
my question is it's kind of intriguing
this idea of the war crimes trials
and their effect on the democracies in
both germany and italy and my question
then to you is
with the lack of the war crime trials in
italy you said it had an effect on their
democracy uh even today and since i'm
not really familiar with uh their
workings of their government could you
give a couple of examples
i mean for me the obvious reason there
has of course to do with the early cold
war yeah
so
uh because of the early cold war there
was very soon an interest to keep italy
in the western camp it was a great fear
from the western side that italy would
turn communist we should not forget that
italy had the strongest communist party
in western or southern europe
and so there was a real chance that in
the 1948 elections for example
the communists could have won these
elections and italy would have turned by
democratic through democratic elections
communist
and that was of course
a fear and that was something that
many wanted to prevent
and
so because of these considerations
denatification or de-facialization
eporatzione was cut short in italy
and uh the whole
[Music]
i mentioned operation sunrise earlier
yeah the the secret surrender of the
german and the s-forces in italy
and this is a good example because some
historians think that operation sunrise
was actually the first shot in the cold
war
yeah
that deal made here between the highest
ranking ss and german commanders in
italy and the oss the us what time
secret under ellen dallas who was in
bern in switzerland and he was
negotiating with the highest as athlete
in italy khal wolfe
and the idea behind that was we want to
make sure italy is not going to turn
communists the communist partisans in
italy not going to take over in the
moment when the germans basically
surrender yeah
we not want to have a vacuum that the
communists can use for their purposes
and turn italy
into a communist country
so in order to facilitate that
some historians think
uh
the american side dallas was very
um
generous
in promising
as kind of a gentleman agreement wolf
his personal protection khal wolf and
that's very important to keep in mind he
was not just the supreme leader of the
ss forces in italy between 1943 and 1945
before 1943 before the fall of 1943 he
was heinrich's himless himmler's
right-hand man he was number two
basically in the ss yeah and after the
war he was not put on trial in nuremberg
he should have been there right him like
that himmler killed himself
khal wolfe should have been there
instead of his boss
but he was not he was shielded from
nuremberg justice so nuremberg of course
in many ways is also selective justice
and karl wolf is a good example he was
spared prosecution because he was useful
in the context of italy and helping to
keep italy so to speak in the western
camp and of course ending the war
earlier and saving many lives this too
absolutely that's important
we have a question in the front row
center
thank you um knowing about the monuments
men or they had a
specific group of people that were going
out and trying to save the art in europe
was there a similar kind of group done
for grabbing the scientists did they
have listed them how how was it
organized
and how far in advance did we decide we
wanted to do this
uh
that was that was operation paperclip it
was originally called all sauce and it
was led by a physicist named samuel
goodsmit and he had a military attache
named boris posh
who later went on to
be a paramilitary officer in the cia
and there's a great parallel there
because as the monuments men were
looking for art
the al sauce group was looking for
scientific intelligence
and i i chronicle this very in great
detail in my book because those early
documents are so interesting and we
learn exactly how this was you know
some would call it plunder and others
would call it you know the the bid for
science and
it was very it was kept very secret and
only when um general
uh eisenhower was set up
in um at the old ig farbin building was
there a real office and the organization
of operation paperclip began and but
what's interesting is it began right in
the ashes of the war but it continued
all the way through to your point um
through when u.s high commissioner john
mccoy
was in
you know office there
and
the scientists were shuttled to the
united states for all of these years and
the program
actually even got a new set of legs
after
that moment in time where the u.s
decided that
we could no longer risk
not having germany be an absolute
partner
against the soviet threat right there on
the border
between east and west
next question to your left
so we've heard a little bit about the
vendettas in
italy
and i think a lot of us are familiar
with jewish nazi hunters in
europe i'm curious mrs holmes
did anything similar happen or is there
evidence of anything like that happening
in japan with the japanese war criminals
well
not really because general macarthur was
in charge
and his
credo
you know prompted by
instructions from washington
was that
the
japanese
were to be
released soon from sugamo prison
they could go through a war crimes trial
and be sentenced some of them were
sentenced for 20 years but they were out
very shortly
uh he commuted their sentences
on instructions from washington
so i don't know if i've answered your
question i might add a note to that
because when i was researching paper
clip it was interesting in a few
instances i came across
the uh the japanese and the japanese war
criminals
um who were who were not prosecuted and
it it sort of falls upon the access of
the biological weapons program so we
took a lot of the nazi scientists to
build up our biological weapons programs
the reich had had most of its facilities
in poland they kept moving them further
east as the allies were attacking and
then ultimately these facilities were
taken over by the russians so the fear
was very real that the russians might
have a better biological weapons program
and so our scientists at fort dietrich
where the weapons program
was went to japan on orders to
uh interview
general ishii who was the leader of
their biological weapons program
and
we caught a deal with him that said you
know and it was a very crafty quid pro
quo if she said if you look at the
documents you know well all you know you
have to grab me clemency full clemency
before i tell you anything
and it went back and forth from the
scientist at fort dietrich who is in
charge of negotiating with him
and the deal was made and they granted
him full clemency and is she handed over
a pile of documents that literally
amounted to absolutely nothing
yes
he was very good at that
a question right in the middle here
this question is for dr steinacher a lot
has been written about the role of pope
pius xii um some accused of being a nazi
collab collaborator others say he spoke
out against what was happening and to
the jews and i guess my take is what's
what's your take on him and what's his
role and should he be held accountable
for his subordinates who were processing
nazis um into south america and
elsewhere
well that's not an easy answer
not easy question to answer i mean
there's no easy answer to this one i
think more research is needed as i
stated earlier
and
i mean
it's also the time frame among christian
responses at the time
based very much on thousands of years of
experience how to come to terms with
such kind or similar atrocities and what
to do after war and you know all these
uh atrocities that were committed and so
the role of forgiveness i think was was
very white but was very strong in
catholic churches
circles and we heard earlier today
the support that
the catholic church but also the
lutheran church
in germany gave to demand to
amnesty or clemency at least to many of
these convicted war criminals that they
called
war prisoners prisoners of war yeah
that was also mentioned this morning so
there was obviously a very different
understanding of guilt and
responsibility from the catholic
leadership side
but
why that is
and what their vision was how to come to
terms with these kind of issues that's
something i'm very much interested in
and i'm certainly going to
research this much more in the next few
years
i'm going to add one note on on
catholicism when i was um
in germany looking at the art the bundes
archives i went to landsberg prison
where six of the paper clips were
originally held before they were one of
whom was re dr otto ambrose who was
convicted of mass murder
and slavery for his work at ig auschwitz
and he was released and he later worked
for the u.s department of energy but i
went to the landsberg prison and the the
fellow who took me around took me into
the the church there and it was very
interesting
almost all of the nazis he said
uh became catholics after the war if
they were not already
and the idea was that they would really
we're just using it as a meeting house
to be able to go
and chat with each other kind of these
secret ideas about how they were going
to get out
and you showed me how they had to do a
redesign of the church
because the benches were such that the
guards couldn't really see who was
whispering to one another so they
redesigned it so that the guards could
be above and look down and sort of give
someone a tap if they were whispering
because in essence they were talking
about you know the how their lawyers
were making progress on getting them out
and they did if i want to add to this
that
absolutely correct so i call it uh
defarcization denatification through
conversion
or repack this in a number of cases the
case that i mentioned earlier eric
who was the head of the gestapo in roman
was corresponsible for the murder of 335
italian civilians some of them were kids
many jews among them
he converted in 19
was got re-baptized in 1948
by a local priest in northern italy and
that was basically if you looked at the
correspondence between this local priest
practicing baptizing uh priebke and huda
in rome this is basically the
precondition in this case for sure of
helping him out and providing him these
new travel documents from the red cross
and as you pointed out um
very very clearly in these prisons there
was a huge effort by the by the
chaplains by the monsignori working
there to convert to to make sure these
nazi heretics
uh
are returning to christ are finding
christ again and this was
an important goal obviously for those
priests not just the local
prison priests but also the higher ups
and i give you another example oswald
paul who was convicted
to
sentence to death because he committed
horrible crimes was responsible for
a large number of victims
so
he converted and he became catholic
imprisoned and his conversion to the
catholic fate was cherished and
celebrated by the catholic authorities
in a publication
the publication was basic was was called
credo my victor got a great i believe my
return to god and he was compared to
saint augustine
oh my goodness
his conversion basically
and and and you have to see this in the
larger context i see this in a larger
context you have millions of former nazi
members yeah
and the catholic
lutheran church the christian churches
in germany austria and italy of course
as well is a catholic country mostly
they wanted to make sure that these
people are coming back to the fold
coming back into the church yeah
that they did deny and and repent the
nazi beliefs these false teachings of
nazism and return back to the true fate
of christianity this was very important
i think that was a very important engine
a motivation for these catholic
priests and monsignor and bishops and
cardinals
next next question on your left
thank you all so much for your
presentation i would like to say one
comment first that
i am not catholic but i do know that
people like monsignor o'flaherty the
scarlet pimpernel of the vatican
did also help jewish and
downed you know flyers from the allied
side to to receive aid
so i know that not all of them were
culpable but
my question actually is about the
difficulties
of establishing new governments in these
in these conquered lands such as west
germany and japan in particular
when you see men standing on the uss
missouri who sign the surrender
agreements
and then
end up becoming part of the new
government
it's
it's appalling
and moral outrage um
when you know about these nazis who
are again put into government leadership
positions
but for the allies when you're trying to
establish a new government who do you
look to
accept people who have already had
political leadership and are bureaucrats
and know how to run a government what
who do you look to
i think it's today as a valid question
with nation building as we call it
i'll speak quickly to that issue because
it is an interesting point today so
that's exactly what happened in post-war
germany
there was a point at which order needed
to be restored and the people who had
the you know the knowledge and the and
the practice were
put back in in power in many instances
what i also find interesting because i
care so much about the the the record of
fact was that these documents were
classified
so many of the of the
the documents that showed culpability
and the reason for that was
to maintain order no one wanted a bunch
of journalists going around and learning
these some of the nature of the crimes
that had been committed by those who
were put in power or became scientists
for the united states
and there's an interesting analogy today
which i noted when i after the iraq uh
the invasion of iraq happened there was
a scientific committee that went in very
much like al sauce and i was following
along as this was happening wondering
are they going what on earth does iraqi
scientists have to author offer
and in fact what they were doing is they
were grabbing documents
because they needed to be able to secret
those documents
so that
those in power the bath party were not
um you know
sort of
killed this in essence and all those
documents went to the hoover institute
at stanford where they remain for
obvious reasons
yeah just a quick uh note to that i mean
i mentioned in my talk that there were
huge efforts in denatification
especially in the american zone of
occupation and 13 million germans were
scanned i mean this is a huge apparatus
and you can see the results and the
effort that went into this
apparatus to this very day if you go to
the national archives in college park
and they look at the berlin document
center materials those materials are
part of the effort of the allies to
collect the materials so they could
screen people where the nazi party
members were the ss members and so on
and so on
so the intentions were there and i think
everything was in place but then of
course at the certain point they
realized so if you
fire basically every teacher who was in
the nazi party and every professor at
the university who was at the nazi party
who's going to run these institutions
and of course ultimate question who has
gone around the country
so there was difficult decision to make
where to draw the line basically this is
there is no easy answer to that in my
opinion
question to your right
my
comments are basically
related to the
comments that have been made by
the speakers and the audience
i think in retrospect
and the history will
bear this fact that both douglas
macarthur and lucius clay
were
two of the most effective
administrators in post-world war
japan
and germany
and partly through their efforts emerged
to modern
democratic states
from the carnage and killing of the of
world war ii
now
if you
fast forward the history
to year 2003
when
mr paul bremer was appointed basically a
macarthur and lucius
clay of iraq
after the fall of saddam hussein
you will see some very clear
distinctions between the past and 2000
between 45
and 2003
mr bremer
outlawed bath party of saddam hussein
basically that move
that one move
created an enormous chaos in the country
because bath party was the only
organization that was capable of running
the country so the the country fell
into chaos
and some historians believe that that
was one of an of a very important reason
for
the syrian civil war rise of isis and so
on and so forth you can certainly debate
this
outcome to some point but i don't think
that that you can really debate what
general macarthur and lucius clay had
done in 1940s thank you
and and the historians don't want to
broach on current affairs
or modern history
i think that's the point i think that's
exactly the point i just made in my
earlier comment yeah
um
you know put in charge
of japan
and so
his attitude
toward
japan and the japanese
after the war
was a crucial factor
and
he
really
proved
the
premise that
you know
he
he was
very sympathetic to the japanese people
and i think that showed
one final question in the center
when my mary band and i went to infantry
ocs in 1967 a lot of time was spent on
the nuremberg principles
both care of pows civilians and a lot
about non-torture and i believe most of
the men i went to vietnam with were
informed by nuremberg and were proud of
how we treated uh the particular war i
was involved with the question i have
now is given the recent united states
apparent
opposition
to joining a uni uh
an international criminal compact
concerning war crimes
has our country renunciated
the wonderful principles i hope we set
at nuremberg
and i know you're historians and i know
it's an uncomfortable question and so if
i could get one answer from each of you
i'd be obliged
well
i
i just don't know
i don't think so
but
you know my colleagues may have more
specific comments
the um the nuremberg trials and the and
the nuremberg code in particular plays
an important role in operation paperclip
because the
doctor that i mentioned dr leopold
alexander who gave us that little crack
into a paperclip's expose
when he made public dr walter
schreiber's presence in the united
states he was responsible for writing
the nuremberg code
based on his experiences at the doctor's
trial co-wrote the nuremberg code
and um
you know it's a
the pow issue in vietnam is
endlessly fascinating to this historian
and
those issues
i think
are issues that
you know individuals as americans should
always be thinking about
and are open to debate and so
i'm not certain that it's a
black and white um
question i think that
i always you know the the hope for all
of this and studying history and to
inform the present
for me comes from eisenhower's remarks
when he talked to us about the
military-industrial complex in his
closing remarks as president
but um he also
had a hopeful
adage which was that
it's the responsibility of americans
to remain informed
and continue in debate
and i think that's what all of us are
doing by attending conferences like this
yeah
i can just repeat what i said earlier i
think the rule of law was very
fundamental looking back with insight
this was really crucial to establish
that
and with nuremberg trials
it was also a way to inform the world
what happened millions of people saw the
newsreels about the liberation of the
camps including the german public
so the german public these images were
there they could not be undone they were
in the heads of these people the german
society it was clear horrible crimes
were committed in italy i had a question
earlier there was no italian nuremberg
the italians never saw you know crimes
that maybe the italian fascist regime
committed in ethiopia or somewhere else
and the view that they had until now on
the crimes or the history of italian
fascism is very often very mild yeah so
i think the the rule of law and these
trials they really made a difference and
helped to start a better democratic
society
well in the tokyo war crimes trials
the
focus
was really on
exonerating
people
japanese war criminals
and
as i said
sugamo prison in tokyo was closed after
a few years because it was empty
but
the
focus on
war crimes and
and uh
the
responsibilities
that came out at the tokyo trials were
really very different
from nuremberg
in my view
ladies and gentlemen
thank you for all of your wonderful
questions
and thanks to our panelists